The absolute worst thing you can do in
the morning is the thing that everyone
tells you that is the best thing to do
in the morning. You ready for this?
Having a good breakfast will start you
off right. And that's a super healthy
habit to do because you don't want to
skip your breakfast if you want to be
healthy. Breakfast is one of the worst
things that you can do. And just hear me
out before you click off because I
completely and utterly believe that this
was true for many years. And most of my
health problems after decades completely
went away when I started skipping my
breakfast. Here you are. You go to sleep
at night. You're not eating through the
night. You are actually fasting. And
most people are fasting for 12 hours.
They're not eating all night long. So
how are they getting their food? Well,
your liver is releasing stored glucose
all night long and everything works
perfectly, right? Until you wake up and
you stop that process. You shut the door
on the liver. And what it's doing, see,
your liver is not just feeding your body
glucose. It's actually in repair mode.
It's doing something called autophagy,
which is a condition where your body is
recycling damaged cells, turning those
into new cells. Your liver is also
burning fat. And so as soon as you eat,
you stop that process. And the most
important thing about this entire video,
which I'm going to get into, is when you
wake up in the morning, your insulin is
at the lowest level of the entire
24-hour cycle. You are in the most fat
burning as well because your fat burning
is directly connected to low insulin
levels. It is true that eggs and bacon
are low carb and this would be an
acceptable breakfast if you just had
eggs and bacon. Some people also do
fruit and cheese, which is not the best.
Other people might do smoothies and
think that's a very healthy thing to do.
But the problem with these two right
here is there's just enough
carbohydrates to stimulate insulin to
start this little process that's going
to happen through the day. But these two
don't even compare to what most people
do is number four, the all-American
breakfast. And this is exactly what I
ate. And that would include the
sweetened yogurts, right? Tons of sugar,
the orange juice or other types of
juices, the sweetened cereals, the
pancakes, the waffles, the muffins. I
remember when I lived in San Diego, I
would go buy these massive muffins in
the morning and consume that with my
coffee as my breakfast. Don't forget the
toast and jam, right? And the jam is
high fructose corn syrup. And what about
hash browns or else sometimes pop tarts,
right? You are creating such a blood
sugar spike in the morning. Like you
completely bump your liver out of fat
burning. You now set up your entire day
for the blood sugar roller coaster ride
and you're going to feel it in your
head. You're going to feel tired. A lot
of people do consume these, but they
also consume eggs and bacon at the same
time. And they might think in their
mind, as long as I'm having protein,
I can also have some of these, right? Or
maybe if I'm consuming these, the extra
protein will help curb and lower my
blood sugars. And it actually does. It
does bring the sugars a little bit
lower. But here is the problem. It does
not bring your insulin levels lower.
Okay? Just the blood glucose levels.
Your insulin level spikes not just with
these carbohydrates, but also with the
protein. That's right. Protein also
increases insulin. If you combine
protein and carbs, you create a doubling
effect of the insulin. I know some of
you are going to say, "Wait a second,
how could you have a lower blood glucose
level?" Maybe you monitor that, but then
have higher amounts of insulin. Well, it
has to do with what protein does with
food in your intestine. It actually
slows down the assimilation of food in
the intestine. So the blood sugar goes
down, but in the background you get this
massive, massive spike of insulin.
Insulin destroys your body 10 times more
if it's very very high. Is it creating
damage? Yes. But it's not creating a
diabetes damage until later when the
insulin starts failing to work and now
the blood sugar goes out of control. And
so let's go through what happens to your
liver if this insulin is high. First of
all, you're not going to be able to burn
fat. Okay? Fat burning is going to be
shut off. All right? So this breakfast,
forget about losing fat. Are you going
to be storing fat? Yes. Your body is
going to be in a fattorring mode. And
this is why your liver becomes fatty
from this breakfast right here. You'll
start to retain sodium. Okay? You're
going to start holding fluid. And if you
just press into your foot, it might
leave a little dent possibly as a
pitting edema. You're going to be
hungry. Why are you gonna be hungry?
Because insulin triggers appetite.
Insulin's going to also cause you to be
inflamed. It's going to cause more
visceral fat in the gut. It's going to
cause the retention of iron, which is
going to create more inflammation in the
liver. It's going to bump you out of
ketosis. So your body is now going to be
dependent on refined glucose. So if
you're going to have this breakfast,
this sweetened carbed out breakfast,
you're going to need to eat something.
Probably just a little something sweet
to get you by till lunch, right? And
then this whole cycle starts over again.
Because there's inflammation, you start
developing fibrosis. That's scar tissue
in the liver. The other thing that
insulin will do is will increase
androgens. In women, that's called
polycystic ovarian syndrome. In men,
you're going to see high levels of DHT.
So, they start losing their hair and
they start having prostate enlargement.
Other than that, they're perfectly fine.
The other thing that's going to happen
in this blood sugar roller coaster is
right after lunch, you're going to feel
tired and want a nap. Around
midafternoon, you're going to want a
snack to get you by till dinner. Okay?
Then you eat and then now we need a
snack at night and then you go to bed
and wake up and start the whole cycle
again. Now what's going to also happen,
you're going to develop insulin
resistance. So at night you're going to
have to pee very often. Two, three,
four, five, six, up to 10 times a night.
I know people that have gotten up 15
times a night. Just think about what
that does to their energy the next day.
if they just get rid of these snacks and
go to two meals a day, it would solve
the problem. The other thing that all
these refined carbs will do is increase
cortisol. So, it's going to start to put
you more in a flight or fight mode,
which you're going to be more in stress
mode versus a calming state. So, now
that you understand that, what would be
the best breakfast to do? Nothing. It
should be no breakfast. Okay? And I'm
going to tell you why. If you just eat
two meals a day with no snacks and go on
a lower carb diet, it forces your body
to burn ketones, which are the byproduct
of fat, and it takes you away from
depending on the calories from the next
meal. And it gets your body to burn your
own fat. So you can easily go from one
meal to the next without being hungry.
You can easily go from your dinner, that
last meal of the day, all the way
through the night to the next day. You
won't be hungry in the morning, okay?
And then you go right to your lunchtime
and then you have that as your first
meal. What I did is I just did a eggs
and bacon breakfast. But it wasn't until
I got rid of the breakfast completely
that I started to really improve my
brain, improve my mental capacity, my
mood, and especially my weight. I was
211 lbs and I went down to 185. Now I'm
like 190. What I would recommend is
first getting rid of these carbs, okay?
Don't keep doing the carbs. If you lower
the carbs, okay, then it's going to be
easier to start tapping in true fat and
make it from one meal to the next. And
then when you wake up in the morning,
just ask yourself, "Am I really hungry?"
And you're going to say, "Well, no, I'm
not." Okay, good. Then don't eat. Don't
eat if you're not hungry. Eat when
you're hungry. So, at first, you can go
in the morning all the way till maybe
10:30 in the morning. Maybe you're
hungry. then eat then and keep pushing
that breakfast further and further
towards the lunch to the point where you
don't need a breakfast. Your first meal
is your breakfast at 12 or 1:00. Okay?
If you do that, so many wonderful things
are going to happen to your liver
especially. You're going to be able to
get rid of the extra fat off the liver
very quickly, probably within a few
weeks. Your inflammation's going to go
down. You're going to reduce the scar
tissue. You're not going to be hungry
between meals. Your belly fat's going to
go away. And I promise you, it'll be one
of the best things to change out of your
lifestyle of all the things you're
doing. Just getting rid of this
breakfast completely.